le corps en un virus qui continuent de
monopoliser l'actualité avec une note
d'espoir en italie une première baisse d
hospitalisation soins intensifs dans la
péninsule
le chiffre passe pour la première fois
depuis février sous la barre des 4000
annonce hier du chef de la diplomatie du
chef de la protection civile pardon je
tiens à vous rappeler comme vous avez pu
le voir dans notre bulletin
aujourd'hui pour la première fois nous
disposons d'une donnée très importante
le nombre de patients en soins intensifs
diminue de 74 unités
c'est une nouvelle importante car elle
permet à nos hôpitaux de respirer c'est
la première valeur négatif depuis que
nous avons commencé la gestion des
urgences le nombre total de guérison et
de vins 1996 par rapport à hier
il y à 1238 personnes de plus qui ont
été guéris un signe également d'une
amélioration les italiens peuvent à
nouveau fréquenter certains marchés en
plein air notamment à rome clients et
commerçants qui est doivent bien sûr
continuer à respecter les règles de la
distanciation sociale et se disent
contents de pouvoir à nouveau faire
leurs courses
un premier pas vers un retour à la vie
normale écoutez ses réactions
dans toutes les têtes et des saveurs
tous là je pense que nous sommes tous
heureux de retrouver marché il ya
beaucoup de gens comme moi ta sont
habitués à acheter des fruits et légumes
au marché ou de produits à l'air plus
frais plus savoureux peut-être même
moins cher pour le sommes contents de
faire à nouveau nos marchés incertains
le gaullisme cette ouverture est le
signe que les choses reviennent à la
normale aussi parce qu'il y a de moins
en moins de personnes infectées
nous espérons que le 13 ou le 14 avril
tour ouvrira même pour toutes ces
personnes qui ont les stands
ce fut une grande perte la crise
sanitaire a mis tout le monde à genoux
le marché n'est toujours pas revenue
comme avant la crise mais bien four
c'est un moment de joie pour nous tous
la réouverture du marché montrent que
c'est simplement un lieu de vie pas
seulement pour nous qui travaillons mais
aussi pour les clients et ceux qui ne
viennent pas faire des achats
certains sont là juste pour la beauté de
ce marché